victor davis hansen has watched all of
this happen
he is a senior fellow at the hoover
institution he joins us tonight um
professor thanks so much for coming on
so you see this massive disconnect you
have this party that's openly and very
aggressively anti-white the democratic
party and yet its leaders including its
leaders of color like the obamas live in
all white neighborhoods how long can
that continue i wonder
oh i don't think it's sustainable and
you know what's new about the border
tucker it's not porous it doesn't exist
they blew it up there is no such thing
as federal immigration law
it's almost an insurrectuary to use that
term act and you ask yourself why why
are three million people gonna come in
the first two years of the biden
administration and the answer is it's
the manifestation of this bi-coastal
elite that's never subject to the
consequences of their own ideology
exactly they want vaccination anybody
that's not vaccine the military out
anybody in the federal workforce out
three million people come in untested on
vacs no problem whatsoever walls are
ossified they're calcified they don't
work but my estate i gotta have a big
wall in malibu or atherton or etc and
then schools we have to have a diverse
school but my kids are going to be at a
private academy and i love diversity but
only as an employer that hires cheap
labor so this is new it really is it's
nihilism and it it really begs the
question why are they doing this it's
almost like it's a psychological
projection so that they're they know
they're guilty that they live apartheid
segregated existences and they don't
want to change it but they think by
performance art virtue signaling and the
abstract i'm for diversity i'm for open
borders then that squares the circle of
their own privilege and i think
everybody's on to them there's only one
i think optimistic chance and that
the hispanic vote
and especially the mexican-american vote
who is mo the community most impacted by
flooded social services and and schools
that are
can't handle this influx and increases
in crime if they vote 50 50
for republican or conservative
candidates in the fall believe me
you will hear the 1992-1996
democratic convention
rhetoric of nancy pelosi chuck schumer
the clintons on how we have to have
legal only immigration because they will
not want to import people who within a
generation or are innately conservative
and you know just to finish you
mentioned all of these hypotheticals
that were really interested i could add
one modest one as we speak tucker our
major universities are in recess there's
about four million dorms nationwide
right now that are empty yes and we hear
all this virtual signaling from stanford
yale princeton these are the ideal
places they have open housing you can
bring in illegal immigrants you can fly
them in they have medical schools they
could offer medical assistance they have
legal uh law schools they can offer
legal assistance they have interns they
can help with
emerging english programs this would be
the solution to the problem the
universities could step up and say we
want to reify our rhetoric with concrete
action we've got the facilities bring
them in i think it would be a wonderful
noble and moral experience if our
college president stepped up and let him
stay and get you know let them
repopulate the universe i'll turn over
cornell to ms-13 and make them students
in the fall their their their endowments
can pay for it they should i couldn't
agree more and i love that idea victor
davis hansen thank you so much for
suggesting that
thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight